es ist ein mindestabstand von zwei
metern untereinander einzuhalten und
alle teilnehmer haben bund und land zu
produzieren zu wollen
69 das tnt was vor allem aus rechten und
verschwörungstheorien kontexten kommt
die gleichen krone lüge hat sie eine
mobilisierung gegeben
diesen aufmarsch zuhörern waren auch
sagen das kann ich wirklich sagen dass
geben die rechnung
verschwörungstheoretiker
hier so frankfurt langdistanz
entschlossen in den weg und sagen nicht
mit uns für österreich aus der stadt
wir wollen das verfahren rassismus keine
meinung sondern ein verbrechen so etwas
hat hier auch keinen kunstrasen nicht zu
suchen
ganz viele menschen sagen dass sie nicht
über den namen deswegen sind wir hier um
intelligenz
wir fordern auch mal kritische fragen
stellen die einsatzleitung der polizei
die uns leben daran hindern wollte er ja
auch die wehmut gehen und
gegendemonstranten der antifaschistinnen
unterstützen ein paar schöne zu zeigen
ich glaube nicht
die stadt eigentlich gewillt gemacht
viel spaß wieder vor der leute
[Musik]
dann kann ich ja gerne für meine kinder
von meinen enkelkindern
ich habe ein
haben der generation unserer älteren
hospitation brauchen dass sie nicht mehr
zu zeigen nicht korrekt war
die haben sich auch noch damals
[Musik]
da beschreiben wollen
fortmann
wir möchten weiter
ganz stark und nixon klammer habe ich
das
davor
befreundet
selber einzuschätzen
wie eine infektion zu bewerten ist
auch viel mehr mit dem herzen haben
die beiden teilen
berechtigen
wir möchten eine demokratische
gesellschaft haben die menschenrechte
geld und nichts kann man denn
eingeschränkt werden wir müssen
eigentlich nur dass wir in frieden leben
können und dass diese kommission 72 1984
formuliert wurde nicht wagen
diese geschichte ist völlig gefertigt da
muss man überlegen ist der schaden
größer durch die meisten behinderungen
wurde reduziert und damit bewusst
wir sitzen leute schon gefallen
natürlich glauben wir dass die andere
seite und wir möchten einfach verhindert
warum werden diese machen müssen wir
diese maske aufsetzen
das ist nicht immer entspricht das
problem dass hier eine neue welt aus dem
sie wollen die welt die menschenrechte
einige wenige der sagt wie zum beispiel
und nur andere menschen zu geld gemacht
haben
von den fraktionen was hier
[Musik]
für seine position und lassen sich
ebenso wie vor nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zu finden ist wie gemacht für möglich
gehalten